hello everyone this is amy here from
audio science review i have a review for
you of this
rcf speaker
if you haven't heard of the company's an
italian company
and the model that i have is this uh
ira pro 5. it comes in five inch this is
the smallest one
and then there's i think six and a half
and then there's an eight inch model uh
you can go to their website i haven't
memorized their model numbers but anyway
this was requested by a couple of
members to be tested so i went ahead and
bought it from amazon us and uh
surprisingly cheap for a power studio
monitor
including uh
shipping from amazon so
hard to imagine how to make these
speakers so cheap and so much stuff
going on in them
this is actually a rare uh dsp speaker
uh
it's biamp so all the signal processing
for the uh crossover is done digital
domain
as is uh some uh correction uh for the
frequency response
done there so uh
usually the lower end powered monitors
that just have uh analog crossover and
no dsb so this have that be at this
price range is quite remarkable
um
nice thing about a professional monitor
is that usually as xlr input and
whenever you use powered speakers i
highly recommend using the xlr
connection
because you have multiple sources of
power usually the speakers plugged in
yet another outlet you have your
computer and everything's got is at the
different ground potential
with respect to safety uh
chassis ground so if you use the rca
you're really oops
really inviting ground loops so
xlr my book is is quite necessary unless
you're using some kind of desktop
monitor where everything's plugged into
where the computer is but in general
you know try to use xlr and you know so
get a dac with the
xlr output to drive it um not a whole
lot else going on here the couple of
boundary uh and the high frequency uh
correction over here i i tend to never
use those leave them at zero for both
measurement and for equalization i do
the eq and software so much more
powerful and flexible but to the extent
you don't have eq capabilities you have
a little bit of of control here
um
uh let's see what else i want to tell
you um
the uh all of almost every speaker
analyst i tell you otherwise is measured
relative to the uh center of the twitter
uh sometimes the manufacturer will
specify a different uh acoustic center i
don't think they did and even if they
did it would be so close to the center
of twitter and such a small speaker that
shouldn't matter
it is front ported you can see these
classic dual eye ports in the front
and ports if you don't know allow you to
have more extended low frequency
response which tends to be very
necessary in this class device but they
do have some drawbacks and we'll get
into that shortly
um
it's a little cool in here and where i
live in northwest washington in the
united states
um so
from experience uh sometimes base
performance suffers a little bit
uh in these colder temperatures
so uh just figured i'd note that uh
usually it's not enough to worry about
but there it is
so
we always start with uh
our acoustic measurements that are done
with the clippable near field scanner
this is a high resolution scan and where
we measure the speaker about a thousand
different points and using the you know
all those measurement points around the
speaker we're able to then model an
entire radiation pattern for that
speaker so we can then project it that
any angle any frequency
we can figure out what the response is
those measurements are then extracted
using the standardized process by cea
and nc i call 2034 that says show me the
on axis response and a few other ones
that i'll talk about
but the most important one is the on
axis response it's in black in here it's
the one that you can see goes up and
down i've drawn a horizontal line which
is an ideal speaker which would have no
variations
and unfortunately here we see some
variation this little bit here is not
that important
but we see a broad increase in energy
from 300 hertz
all the way up to uh one and a half
kilohertz
then we have a dip
and then after that is sort of more or
less good enough it would be nice if it
didn't go up like this but uh you know
that's that's a minor thing
and whenever you see peaking in in here
that's replicated and all the other
graphs means there's a resonance means
something
you know your note that you hit and also
the the speaker starts to amplify that
on its own more than it should
and those resonances are colorations and
sound that we prefer to not see if it
doesn't show up in the other graphs that
means it's just it's just in the on-axis
chances of it being audible slow but
here clearly we see the resonances here
we see them here we see them here we see
them here so
and so for sure it's there are
resonances so
um instead of going further and
analyzing more of this graph
i do another measurement where i take a
microphone and the same measurement
microphone and i put it very close to
each driver and the port and measure
that by doing that more or less we
exclude the contribution from the other
components of a of a speaker so without
taking it apart we're able to see what
the twitter is doing what the woofer is
doing what the port is doing
so here um the strong red one is the
woofer response and you know it handles
low frequencies and then at some point
the crossover and the response of the
woofer itself starts to go down then it
has some breakups that happen up here at
very high frequencies but the
amplitude's uh quite low for it and then
twitter response is this one in teal or
blue depending on what color you're
seeing
on this thing so we can see the
crossover more or less here and some
resonances close to the high frequency
at the end of the spectrum
the biggest thing i've noticed the port
though
i put a microphone in front of the uh
one of the holes
and measure that at first we see what
ports are supposed to do which is
generate a lower frequency
than the woofer itself can do so the
woofer response is down but we can see
that at this point the port is
contributing and is able to flatten the
base response which is by the way quite
excellent uh this thing is flat to 60
hertz which is quite remarkable for a
little speaker like this where you could
just pick up with one hand but you know
he's got a flat base down to 60 hertz
not just rolled off or responding but
actually flat response which is pretty
good
and then so going back to this this is
the goodness that the port provides
unfortunately inside the cabinet you can
get resonances that are proportional to
the
dimensions of the speaker vertical and
horizontal and widthwise
and those resonances need to be
controlled otherwise
basically the speaker speakers singing
in those tunes
if you don't do anything to to absorb
those they just come out of the hole uh
and in this case the holes are
unfortunately in the front the ports in
the front so they're quite a bit more
audible than if the port was in the back
for some reason these front ports have
become popular because they think
somebody's going to stick these speakers
literally into a wall
nobody does that these days
just one or two inches of distance from
the wall is good enough to let the rear
port breathe so i much rather prefer to
see a port that's
firing backwards because then these
things have to first reflect from the
wall then come to you and that distance
attenuates them
whereas if they're in the front they act
like basically other speakers that that
are spitting out these tones
and these this is unfortunate in a lot
of times these resonances from the cabin
and the port land where the crossover is
which means where the speakers the
weakest here we reducing the output of
the woofer for the crossover and then
this thing comes in with a you know very
you know strong resonance so it actually
you can see how it's pushed up the
response over here and it does it again
over here and it'll do it again over
here so it's where the speaker is most
vulnerable we have resonances so that's
another technique is to try to
size the enclosure in a cabinet where
these resonance frequencies at least
land you know here
where
they're not where the you know woofers
response gone down so if it's here and
it's trying to compete with a stronger
output from woofer it has a harder time
but when the woofer is rolling down by
many db then all of a sudden you have
resonance it takes the overall response
and unscrews it up basically and this is
the classic coloration you get from a
port that's designed this way
on this thing uh
but there are a lot of good things in
here and i'll get to them in a second
but and one of the things that i'll show
you proof of in a second is that this
has good directivity which because of
that wave guide that's there in front
the sort of horn looking thing
um it's able to produce an off axis
response that's similar to on access and
as a goodness we bond
the drawback of that is that what was
wrong with on-axis also shows up in
off-axis so we see all this coloration
over here
all you know are there and the trough
gets deeper and so it makes it even
worse in here by the way company is
unique and almost unique in that they
have proper measurements for something
that's cheap on their website
and they more or less match my
measurements they're very smooth theirs
are as is typically the case but overall
they also
show the dips and the peaks that that
you see in my response
if you were to use the speaker in far
field meaning for stereo listening as
opposed to studio monitoring
we have models that predict what the
strongest reflections are that combine
with direct sound and then we can create
a composite
tonality curve for the speaker if we
apply that we see that it is not very
good
we have extra energy in this area and
upper base and and
mid range and then we have a hole in
here then it actually smoothed out is
fine so
this changes the tonality of a lot of
stuff in your music and content because
you know so much is going on in your
music here not a whole lot going on way
out here uh on this so
there's good engineering in here but
somehow this this port thing was allowed
to happen uh where it is now you can see
example of excellence in engineering and
this beam width this says that if we
pick something like a 6db drop-off
as you go off axis
what does that curve look like and the
curve looks beautiful it's almost flat
which is unusual this is extremely good
we're talking general like a neumann
kind of uh professional monitor at far
higher prices able to achieve this kind
of linearity in beam with
and also means that you can go left and
right and the sound will not change much
at all the tonality remains the same
which is important when you work in near
field just slight movement you're moving
a fair amount of angle away from the on
axis response
so you want this kind of you know large
beam width and smoothness sometimes you
get smoothness but it's very narrow and
so if you go outside of that all sudden
drops like a brick
we can see the same thing color coded in
here and you can see how how pretty it
is how beautiful this and that it's just
very smooth and predictable and then it
narrows the highest frequencies which is
expected
uh vertically it's
more chewed up uh but that's expected uh
basically the uh
woofer and the twitter are not
concentric and so when you go up and
down depending on what distance you go
up and down relative to the distance
between the center of those two drivers
you get cancellations in addition so
forth um so
pointing the speaker at your ear that's
how i tested it i have it pointed up in
my when i normally test it i didn't test
it there and
and have it point to your ear and
usually your height doesn't change that
much but if you stood up you know you
will get
uh you know some of the frequency
response that's not very good you'll run
into these holes so stay within plus and
20 plus or minus 20 degrees and you
should be fine um the only solution to
that problem is to get a coaxial uh
driver where the center of the twitter
is inside uh the woofer and that has its
own challenges with power handling other
things but under activity but so don't
be alarmed with this one being the way
it is
i measure distortion at two points 86
dbs spl or 96 uh at 86 db response is
quite good other than this one spike in
here so something in there around
300 hertz is sinking inside there
whenever you see a distortion profile
that's very narrow usually means the
resonance and you can see it over here
also it doesn't show up that much in
frequency response but clearly some
other thing is starting to sink in there
and therefore it amplifies harmonic
distortions
uh of other tones lower frequencies get
amplified and show up in here as
distortion
so
i wish that wasn't theirs otherwise 86
db response is very good 96 db that
resonance goes through the roof but also
woofer gets very unhappy this is very
typical of a small speaker like this
woofer gets unhappy you have to go way
up above the speaker in power handling
to not have a woofer uh get unhappy at
96 db spl um so
you know the woofer is unhappy usually
twitter doesn't get unhappy and that's
what we see in here but the woofer is
unhappy
detecting distortion at lower
frequencies thankfully is harder so if
you're going to have distortion or
rather see it here then in the mid
frequencies here
i run a waterfall display and these
displays can be very very misleading
basically this is frequency response
over time and there's so many parameters
involved in generating this graph that i
can make it look like anything i can
make it look like a perfect speaker or i
can make it look like it's the worst
speaker in the world but i'm more or
less going in biddle and show you
something which is in this case anything
that sort of hangs on and keeps going uh
is a resonance and we can see these
resonances around two three hundred
hertz that we saw in the distortion
spike and but also the ones from the
port and the cabinet going all the way
up to one kilohertz and even beyond in
here so
you know this just backs up uh it's not
needed because we already knew this
information anyway um you can see the
impulse response actually pretty clean
that's one of their claim to fame with
the fair filtering
and you can also see the step response
the sharp one is a twitter and the slow
one is the woofer uh you know i i don't
usually pay attention to either one of
these measurements but some people like
to see them
so
when i played
the speaker
it wasn't annoying or anything and it
had some signs of excellence in their
occasion i would hear a note and say
that sounds good but overall i wasn't
getting excited over the sound of it and
but you know it was hard to put a finger
on it doing what was wrong but i had the
measurements so i said all right let me
go create filters in drone player which
is what i use
and i use a parametric eq and what's
nice about
metric eq is that i can design
independent filters and then turn them
on and off independently not all or
nothing and see if if i'm getting better
performance or not and the the response
if you go back to on-axis response
it's really
chewed up so to make a proper correction
you'd have to build a lot of filters in
there to
fix each one of these things excuse me i
took a shortcut and i said like i have a
hump in here and why not just put an
inverted hump in the eq so i just took
all this as if it's continuous and i put
one down the inverse of that in eq i
have a dip in here so i assume that it
was just carved out like this and i put
it inverted one above and this thing was
going up so i just put another one going
down i didn't try to match the exact
deviation and so forth so only three
filters um so let's go back to that
again
uh so i've got this filter in here and
i've set up the width of it to be quite
wide to cover that entire region and
then a narrower one because that's all
that little ditch was and then again
this one i just put in
this will be to taste depending on how
much brightness you want and how good
your hearing is i tend to not like too
much brightness and the speakers are
maybe more aggressive here you may be
okay with out-of-box response and not
even need this and let's say there's a
switch in the back you could also throw
that switch and see if that was enough
uh that's enough to get rid of this so
three simple filters in here
and when i first dialed them in to be
honest i was like okay that sounds a
little bit better and as i was working
on the review i was listening to it with
the filters on
and then after um you know maybe 10 or
15 minutes i went back and then rooney
can turn off all the filters at once and
it was dramatic when you turned it off
also the sound got a little bit a little
bit more bass but also became a
bit boomy is not the right word but it
just became too much of that upper base
and because of this ditching here
because of this it also sounded less
interesting and more close i find that
any deficiency in sort of one to three
kilohertz takes away that ambience that
openness that sound can have
and so turning it off it was like oh i
don't want to listen to it even though
it wasn't terrible it it did it was so
dramatic in in listening to a correct
response and then making it broken as
opposed to when we first listened to it
and i was like okay there's a filter did
it make it better did not
um one other beautiful thing about this
approach that i use is that one it
confirms the measurements to be correct
so in my view
everything that we saw at macro level at
least in measurements were correct these
corrections definitely made the thing
sound better but you might say well
that's cited you're looking at
measurements well you could just close
your eyes and and do these things blind
i often do that where i randomize these
these whether it's on or off and then i
just leave my cursor on it without
looking at the ui i can hit
you know toggle the switch on and off on
and off and then decide which one's
better than i'd look and i'll say okay
did i pick the eq version or non-eq
version and sometimes that happens where
i'm like oh you know i picked the non-eq
as being better then i play some other
music and then it's the other way when
that's the case i just throw my hands up
in here and i either don't provide the
filters or i'll tell you that i couldn't
conclusively decide when the filters
were good in this case i could and uh
you know obviously it is subjective and
it's my ears and and not yours so uh you
can choose to uh
go by him or not
and um so overall i thought just a bit
of correction was enough
on this thing
one problem with these active speakers
especially at lower price point is is
twitter hiss
because you don't have a passive
crossover anymore there's nothing to
reduce the efficiency and eat up some of
that noise
and the amplifiers and dsp they tend to
use is on the noisy side you know it's
150 speaker they can't afford to put
state-of-the-art uh technology in there
um i've noticed that for example jbl ls
series the you know the 305 can be the
twitter hiss you can hear it when it's
paused at three to four feet this one
has
his
but past about seven or eight inches i
couldn't barely hear it
i do have my computer running so a
little bit of noise being masked there
but i'd say it's not perfect but it's
definitely on the good side and at
listening distance of three to four feet
five feet i don't think you're going to
hear the
the highs even in a i mean the noise
even in a quiet room
the uh one of the nice thing was the
power handling um there is dynamic
compression in there that protects the
amplifiers and protects the speaker from
being overdriven a lot of superbly
designed uh
active speakers have a problem that as i
crank it up also the amplifier runs out
of juice and it will crackle it'll
create static and or they'll also
compress
uh and for that reason i don't those
speakers i don't give the highest
remarks uh rewards because it just
to me there shouldn't be a technology
limitation that all sudden hits you in
the nose um this one has a nice limiter
in it you turn it up and it gets quite
loud even though i'm listening to just
one speaker and then it gets to a point
where you turn it up more and more it
just refuses to get louder
and so it's like a suspension in there
there's no hard limit in there and it
gets to a point and then it just
gradually says okay you know you told me
to go
50 louder i'm only going to go five
percent um at this price range
is great i couldn't detect any
driver bottoming out or the amplifier
generating static which is very very
good
so to me
oh
many things are done correctly in this
rcf
speaker it's just the one thing is just
front ports which is fashionable in this
industry and the fact that you know at
this price range they probably couldn't
afford to put you know
exotic material and they're a better
filtering inside or design they're sort
of restricted to where they could put
the boards in there
when they're in the front whereas in the
back you can move it around to try to
minimize some of those effects go left
and right
and
but i also think that they could have
done better and they can do better
because this thing is programmable dsp
based
so i've sent them a message asking for
feedback and
and confirmation to see if they've got
the same measurements and they wanted
the frequency response that looks the
way it does
or that their measurements are too rough
and they didn't see all the issues that
i found and maybe now they can
apply a correction i'll let you know
what they say i don't know if they'll
answer or not but i did contact them
because i think it's just too good of a
speaker for it to have this one flaw if
it didn't have this flaw this would be
an incredible speaker yes once you go to
250 300 you can get very nice speakers
but 149 and at 149 you're getting
two amplifiers you get an analog digital
converter back to that digital to analog
because this thing will digitize the
input to do the dsp you're getting dsp
correction
you're getting balanced input you're
getting you know proper speaker
only 149
each so to me if it didn't have this one
issue with the board resonances this
would be just such an incredible value
it would really cement this place at
this price level no way you can match
this thing with any kind of passive
speaker you know that you have to you
know have add up because of the amp and
everything else to it it should you're
just not going to get an optimized
design for 149 dollars that's flat down
to 60 hertz
so anyway
um
came close came close to being a very
very good speaker but
it didn't quite get there um if you go
on a forum there we have other members
that do uh
full eq based on you know all those
drops and peaks and generate a what we
call olive score for this which i think
was around 3.5 3.6 without eq but it
jumped up to 5.6 or so with eq so
just a bit of eq
really lifts the score of this speaker
saying this more neutral and and good
so without eq i think it's fine it
sounds okay and maybe good
but i really hope somebody who's using
this in the desktop environment
like me if you're doing professional
audio work then you have full control to
eq
go ahead and create one with these just
two three simple filters and have a
beautiful speaker without it i'm
nebulous as to whether you know you want
to use it or not um looking at what the
membership voted based on my data looks
like everybody is sort of straddling
between not terrible and fine which is i
think the right rating
but it could have been fine to great if
it
came with that eq built in
okay hopefully this was useful to you
and if you're not interested in this
speaker as far as measurements and what
makes a good speaker and what
causes problems for us okay see you in a
future one bye